Guten Tag. Aktaika ist mein Name und ich bin hier Assistenz Erst.
So erst möchte ich ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Person stellen, dann kommen wir gleich zu Ihren Beschwerden. Ist das in Ordnung?
Hallo, guten Tag. Ja bitte, aber ja, fragen Sie mal.
Wie heißen Sie?
Michael Gaibel.
Wie alt sind Sie, Herr Gaibel?
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Ist das so wichtig? So 95 Kilo ungefähr.
Wie groß sind Sie, Herr Gaibel?
Ich war einmal 1,83.
Wo ist die Hausarzt?
Mein Hausarzt ist Frau Gabriele Zieten.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Hausarztnachnamen buchstabieren?
Zieten, das ist Zeppelin, Ida, Emi, Zivitirda, H.W. Heinrich.
Und dann E. und N.W. Nordpol. Zieten.
Frau Zieten.
Danke schön. Was bürcht Sie so um? Welche Hauptbeschwerden haben Sie im Moment?
Also ich habe gestern so starke Rückenschmerzen zwischen den Schulterblättern.
Und das strahlt in meinen linken Arm aus bis hier zu meinen Fingerspitzen.
Sind die Beschwerden plötzlich oder langsam aufgetreten?
Also die sind gestern eigentlich relativ schnell und plötzlich aufgetreten.
Das war am Anfang nicht so schlimm, aber das hat sich jetzt gestern doch sehr verschlechtert.
Also ich konnte heute Nacht nicht schlafen.
Und der Arm wird auch ganz komisch.
So ein bisschen taub habe ich das Gefühl.
Ich habe das Gefühl, ich habe wenig Kraft im Arm.
Und die Schmerzen werden nicht besser.
Also obwohl ich glaube, ich glaube, ich habe seit gestern mindestens fünf bis sechs Tabletten Evo-Profen genommen.
Ich habe zusätzlich noch Novalgin genommen.
Aber das hilft nicht.
Das ist immer nur für einen kurzen Moment besser.
Und dann geht es aber gleich wieder weiter.
Können Sie die Schmerzen genauer beschreiben?
Zum Beispiel stehend drücken oder elektrischer Schmerzen?
Das habe ich ja gerade eben gesagt.
Ich habe zwischen den Schulterblättern sehr starke Schmerzen.
Das sticht manchmal ja.
Das ist so, dass es sich so verursacht.
Und das strahlt in den linken Arm aus.
Und der Arm ist ein bisschen kraftlos und etwas taub.
Was ist passiert gestern Abend, wo diese Schmerzen aufgetreten?
Ich habe eigentlich nichts gemacht.
Ich habe am Tag im Garten gearbeitet.
Wir haben so viele Pflanzen und einfach kleine Bäume.
Die habe ich dann gefällt.
Ich musste auch mal zwei, drei schwere Kisten tragen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob es das war.
Aber während der Arbeit war nichts.
Es war alles in Ordnung.
Das ist etwas, was ich eigentlich auch immer wieder mache.
Genau.
Wie stark sind die Schmerzen auf einer Scala von 1BC?
Ich würde sagen, gestern waren sie ganz mild.
Bei zwei vielleicht, aber heute schon sehr stark.
Ich würde sagen, 8-9.
Können Sie jetzt sofort ein Schmerzmittel oder schaffen Sie es bis später?
Es wäre schön, wenn ich etwas bekommen könnte.
Die Schmerzen werden jetzt auch wieder schlimmer.
Ich habe heute Morgen schon zwei Iberprofen genommen.
Aber das hilft immer nur ganz kurz.
Genau.
Haben Sie bekannte Allerbien gegen Medikamente?
Nein, ich habe mich nicht bekannt. Ich vertrag alles.
Genau.
Ich gebe jetzt ein Schmerzmittel, Spritzerform.
Und wie geht es Ihnen im Moment?
Es scheint ein bisschen zu wirken.
Es wird ein bisschen weniger.
Aber es geht nicht ganz weg.
Sind die Schmerzen dauerhaft oder kommen und gehen weg?
Wenn ich Medikamente nehme, wird es ein bisschen besser.
Aber dann kommen die wieder.
Nach zwei Stunden sind sie wieder ganz heftig.
Gibt es etwas, was die Schmerzen festhalten oder erlindert?
An sich nicht.
Egal, wie ich mich setze oder mich drehe, mich bewege oder mich hinlege, das ist immer gleich.
Immer gleich.
Hätten Sie eine Hebischwerte rühren?
Nein. Aber ich habe noch nie gehabt, das ist das erste Mal.
Genau.
Herr Doktor, wieso sagen Sie immer genau?
Okay.
Verstanden.
Wie ist Verstanden?
Okay.
Sie meinen, dass Sie haben es verstanden.
Haben Sie Fieber?
Nein.
Wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Ganz gut. Also ich habe bisher kein Problem mit dem Essen.
Haben Sie Abgenommen oder Fuggenomen?
Nein.
Ich bin ungefähr auf dem gleichen Gewicht seit vielen Jahren.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang oder wasselles?
Nein, bisher eigentlich alles ganz gut.
Genau.
Haben Sie Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Jetzt durch die vielen Tabletten habe ich schon eine leichte Übelkeit.
Haben Sie Erbrechen?
Nein.
Nur eine leichte Übelkeit.
Genau.
Verstanden.
Haben Sie Brustenge oder Brustschmerzen oder weitere Beschwerden?
Kann ich so nicht sagen, aber ich tue mir ein bisschen schwer, wenn ich einatme.
Dann wird es auch ein bisschen eng auf der Brust schon, aber ich weiß nicht, ob es vom Rückhänden kommt.
Sie überlegen sich noch etwas, Herr Doktor?
Ja. Ich nur denke, was ...
... was ...
... Frage, Frage kann.
Ah, Sie denken, welche Fragen Sie fragen wollen, ja wollen.
Ich warte.
Haben Sie bestimmte chronischen Erkrankungen, wie zum Beispiel ...
... Artilial-Bluthochdruck, Zuckerkrankheit und so weiter?
Ich habe nur einen hohen Blutdruck und dann nehme ich Medikamente, aber das ist immer ganz gut eingestellt gewesen.
Seit wann haben Sie Bluthochdruck?
Oh, seit 15 Jahren ungefähr.
Okay.
Ist Ihre Bluthochdruck gut angestellt oder?
Ja, habe ich ja gerade gesagt, es ist gut eingestellt. Ich nehme das Rami-Pri 5 Medikap ...
... und der Amnodipin 10 Milligramm.
Wie viel mal pro Tag?
Amnodipin eine am Morgen und Rami-Pri eine am Abend.
Und weiter Erkrankungen haben Sie?
Nein, nein, bisher alles okay.
Haben Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Ja, ich habe früher gerne mal Fußball gespielt und da hatte ich meinen Knie verletzt.
Das war so ein Kreuzpantriss. Das war das rechte Knie, aber das ist schon sehr, sehr lange her.
Sind Sie operiert?
Oh, da war ich, glaube ich, 30 Jahre alt.
Sind diese Operationen komplikationlos oder?
Ja, es gab keine Probleme, das war alles gut.
Ich merke, wenn ich wieder zu viel laufe, Treppen schneige oder auch wieder Fußball spiele, dann bekomme ich wieder Knie-Schmerzen.
Also da muss ich ein bisschen langsamer machen. Das merke ich schon.
Verstanden.
Haben Sie irgendwelche regelmäßige oder elegante Medikamente ein?
Sie sagen, dass sie eine amnodipin und Rami-Pirale einnehmen.
Und weitere Medikamente, elegante oder?
Nein, habe ich jetzt nicht. Nur halt über Profil, wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe.
Haben Sie allergen oder Unverträglichkeiten gegen bestimmte Lebensmittel oder so weiter?
Nein, ist nichts bekannt.
Rauchen Sie, Herr...
Ich habe früher mal geraucht für ein paar Jahre, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Können Sie weiter sagen, bitte?
Also ich habe früher mal geraucht, nur eine kurze Zeit, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Wie viele Zigarette pro Tag früher geraucht?
Das waren nur vier oder fünf Zigarette, also das waren nicht viel.
Seit wann?
Seit wann haben Sie geraucht diese fünf Folgen?
Das war für zwei, drei Jahre und ich habe seit zehn Jahren eigentlich nicht mehr geraucht.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Sehr selten.
Und wie oft trinken Sie?
Wenn man beim Essen ist, zum Beispiel, ein bisschen Wein, mehr ist es nicht.
Das ist vielleicht einmal die Woche.
Einmal die Woche.
Welche Alkohol trinken Sie?
Also ich trinke gerne Wein.
Wein?
Das ist ein schöner Rotwein zum Essen, das ist meistens immer ganz gut.
Ultimäßig muss ich fragen, bitte, nicht persönlich kann.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen gehabt?
Mit Drogen? Nein, nein, nein.
Okay.
Was sind Sie von Beruf?
Ich bin Ingenieur, Maschinenbau Ingenieur, arbeite bei einer großen Firma.
Sind Sie verheiratet?
Ja.
Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, eine Tochter und einen Sohn.
Die sind aber auch schon ein großer Erwachsen.
Die Tochter ist 35, der Sohn ist 39.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, glücklicherweise.
Der Minister ist jetzt nicht bekannt, dass die krank wären.
Zum Glück.
Mit wem wohnen Sie?
Wir sind meine Frau zusammen.
Nur seine Frau.
Ja.
War das das, oder haben Sie noch Fragen geteckt?
Ja, ein bisschen Fragen, nur Ihre Familienanalyse.
Und Preisesport und Impfungen.
Leiden Familienangehörige an wichtige Erkrankungen,
z.B. Zugeerkrankheiten, Bulltochter, Krebs und so weiter?
Nicht, dass ich rüste nach Hause.
Beim Vater oder Mutter?
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe eine Schwester, aber die ist auch gesund.
Da wüsste ich jetzt nicht, dass ich da irgendwas hätte.
Genau.
Wann waren Sie das letzte Mal im Urlaub?
Urlaub, gut.
Wozu diese Frage verstehe ich nicht, das ist ja im letzten Sommer.
Da waren wir in Italien.
Warum?
Das ist eine Routinefrage.
Echt?
Ja.
Wie ist Ihr Impfstatus?
Impfstatus.
Kindererklankheit, Covid-19.
Ich bin regelmäßig bei meinem Hausarzt.
Überprüft auch immer meine Impfungen.
Also sollte eigentlich komplett sein.
Ja.
Treiben Sie regelmäßig Sport?
Ich versuche.
Ich fahre einmal in der Woche mal ein bisschen Fahrrad.
Und gehe auch am Wochenende joggen.
Fahrrad und weiter?
Joggen.
Okay.
Wir sind jetzt fertig.
Haben Sie noch Informationen, die wichtig sein könnten?
Ich bin jetzt da, Doktor.
Mir macht es natürlich Angst.
Was ist das für Schmerzen?
Ich hoffe, Sie finden es bald raus.
Jetzt haben Sie mich so viele Fragen gestellt.
Ich verstehe, dass Sie sich Sorgen machen.
Wir werden alle notwendige Unterdrücken,
die Sie auf der Runde durchführen.
Okay.
Ich werde die erste Körperunterzüge durchführen.
Ich werde die Labelunterzüge durchführen.
Und dann können weitere Unterzüge wie EKG, CT oder MRT nötig sein.
Was ist CT?
Computerpomografie.
Ah, okay. Alles klar.
Und so was, die ich die Ergebnisse habe, erkläre ich Ihnen alles in Bühe.
Und das wird alles heute noch gemacht, oder?
Das wird alles heute noch gemacht?
Nein, MRT nach einer Termin vereinbaren für Sie
und die weitere Unterzüge, die heute gemacht werden.
Okay, alles klar. Danke.
Danke schön.
Okay, danke schön.
Ich habe einen Kollegen, der einen Kollegen noch kann, die Sie fragen.
Ich kann es noch mal machen.
Ich habe es noch mal machen.
Nein.
Ich habe es noch mal gemacht.
Ja, das ist gut, Herr Kollege.
Ich habe es noch ein bisschen schmissen, aber...
Es ist sehr gut, danke schön.
Danke schön.
Ich habe es noch ein bisschen schmissen, aber...
Guten Tag Herr Oberast.
Ich würde Ihnen gerne einen Patienten...
Ah, der unsere Junus. Hallo Herr Doktor.
Was haben Sie für einen Patienten?
Den ich gerade eben in der Notaufnahme gesehen habe, haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, natürlich. Bitte schön.
Herr Geibel, 2,6 Jahre alt, 1,83 m groß und 5,9 kg schwer.
Ich höre, erzählen Sie weiter.
Der Patient stammt bei uns vor Aufgrund,
seit gestern Abend,
bestehender plötzlich aufgetretener,
starker Rückenschmerzen nach dem Gartenarbeit.
Und der Patient sagte, die Schmerzensstrahlung
in den Fingerspezeln aus.
Die Schmerzintensität wurde mit 8 bis 9 von 10 auf der Schmerzskala bewertet.
Darüber hin und her erwähnt er das Schmerzen,
die vegetative Anamnese ist unaufwählbar,
bis auf Schmerzbedingte Schlachtstörungen.
Anvor Erkrankungen leidet der Patient an arteriellen Pätonis
seit 15 Jahren gut angestellt und nehme mit Romypril 5 mg abends,
mit Romypril 5 mg morgens behandelt.
Ruhsätzlich,
zu den genannten Medikamenten,
die Mediapatiens gelegen und profen und normalen Tablete.
Der Patient hatte 30 Jahre alt,
eine Kreuzband rückdurchgeführt worden.
Also, jetzt muss man das Platz aber richtig sagen.
Der Patient hatte, als er 30 Jahre alt war, einen Kreuzband riss.
Der Patient sei,
der Patient sei vor 30 Jahren eine Kreuzbandruptür durchgeführt worden.
Da muss man bei den Patienten sei vor 30 Jahren eine durchgeführt worden
oder Patient habe vor 30 Jahren eine Operation gehabt.
Okay, gut, eine grammatikalische Situation, etwas kompliziert,
aber es geht ja wohl.
Er sei keine Allergie oder Unverträglichkeiten.
Er ist bekannt.
Er ist nicht rauf seit 10 Jahren.
Und davor 5 bis 6 Zigaretten pro Tag seit 10 Jahren.
Und trinken englische Rotwein,
gelegentlich provohe am Bohnen.
Und Drogenkonsum wurde verneint.
Er sei Maschineningenieur,
verheiratet und habe zwei Kinder.
Sie sind gesund.
Familienanamnese ist unauffällig.
Aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich den Verdacht auf ein He-Wathe-Pose-Diskussprolaps.
Was war ein Prolaps?
Halswirbel-Saure.
Soil, also ein HWS, ein HWS, als Halswirbelsäulenprolaps.
Als Differentialdiagnosen in Akut-Coronär-Sendrom,
Diabetese-Neuropathie.
Wieso Diabetese? Hat der Auto kein Diabetes der Patient?
Das ist nur ein Differentialdiagnose.
Ja, wenn wir treten Diabetese-Neuropathien akut auf?
Nein, Sie sind richtig. Diabetese-Neuropathie, kein Differentialdiagnose.
Sie haben gesagt, es ist ein HWS-Syndrom, wahrscheinlich ein Prolaps.
Sie denken von einem akuten Koronasyndrom, auch da haben Sie gesagt, okay.
Vielleicht Spinalcanalsythenoza und eine maligene Metastasie, ihre Halswirbelsäule.
Soil.
Und nach der Gartenarbeit und einer Proaktur, kann ich sagen, kann sein könnte.
Kann sein könnte. Okay, woher denken Sie noch?
Und wegen der Diabetese-Neuropathie,
Halswirbelsäule höre ich zuerst eine körperliche Untersuchung
und mit Fokus auf neurologische Untersuchungen durch.
Dabei achte ich besonders auf...
Stopp, also was müssen Sie als Erstes machen?
Sie haben vorhin gesagt, Sie haben einige Diagnosen, Ihre Verdachtsdiagnose,
Leute hat sie eine Differentialdiagnose geäußert.
Was kommt als Erstes?
Muskelspannung...
Eine von den Untersuchungen meine ich. Sie haben akutes Koronasyndrom, wie gesagt.
Ein EKG-Schreibung.
Das Erste, das Allererstes, ist ein EKG.
Ja.
Und machen ein Troponin, ein Schnelltest.
Damit Sie einen akuten Herzinfarkt ausschließen können.
Das ist das Erste.
Wenn das ausgeschlossen ist, machen Sie dann weiter.
Sie sagen, das ist ein Prolaps. Welche Untersuchungen brauchen Sie dafür?
Ich untersuche Ihre...
Diagnostik meine ich. Welche Diagnostik?
Diagnostik.
Neurolinche Untersuchungen.
Und eine MRT...
Genau, Sie brauchen ein MRT. Diagnose zu sichern.
Nötig sein.
Um die Diagnose zu sichern, brauchen Sie ein MRT.
Genau.
Okay. Sehr gut.
Aber an welchen Differenzialdiagnose denken Sie noch?
Was läuft entlang der Wirbelsäule?
Das hat mir vorhin schon gehabt.
Ich sagte, dass vielleicht eine Malin metastas...
Das ist richtig, aber das sieht man hier auch.
Röntgen durchgeführt und frakturalsüßchen...
Aber ich meine nicht, das haben Sie schon gesagt.
Eine andere Differenzialdiagnose.
Die Kollegen können ruhig helfen.
Wir haben das bei dem anderen Fall beim anderen Doktor auch schon gehabt.
Was läuft vor der Wirbelsäule?
Und oben ist ein großes Gefäß.
Wie heißt dieses Gefäß?
Arteriell oder...
Überach im Arse-Mann.
Ich habe heute der einzige Vorschläge gemacht.
Natürlich, Sie müssen auch an den Arten die Sektion denken.
Wenn Sie ab 65 sind gefährdet für eine Artenanorysma.
Das kann auch in der Spondan-Dissektion führen.
Sie müssen immer an die Sektion denken.
Diese Differenzialdiagnose muss ich eine Kontrastmittell-Tomographie...
Ein Beispiel, ja.
Durchführen oder untersuchen, laschen.
Sie sind notfallaarzt, deswegen nur Röntgen und Maximum-Kompitettomographie.
Kein Kontrastmittel.
Kontrastmittel, Kompetetomographie und MR nicht deine Arbeit.
Doch, muss man mit dem Oberarzt besprechen.
Danke schön.